[Music]
you want me to have a heart attack right
now
oh don't do that chuck
that's my libby's dad cried like a baby
after the cookout he threw to try to
bring his family together turned into a
full-on brawl between andre and libby's
brother
charlie
elizabeth even started going at it with
charlie's wife
who i've never really heard talking till
now
[Music]
and she had a lot to say so did becky's
husband
they're both to blame they're both blame
you guys too it's all toxic thomas said
we are too good for this mess
he is over it just like a lot of us are
it's too much trailer traps
we'll get into all the standout moments
from this family's latest fiasco
in just a few plus i live in a different
country
i've been changing a lot from the bad
to the good what do you have done asuelu
tries to persuade kalani to move to
samoa with him
after her mom drops the bomb that she
and kalani's dad are selling the house
and they need to move out hey 90 day
fans fam
it's melisia we are basically done with
season eight of happily ever after
this was the last episode before part
one of the tell-all special
which looks like it's going to be
tell my wild what to do these brand new
beads what was all these how do you like
that no
angela went and turned the tell-all into
the mari show
yes that's her back in the day also
natalie and mike are gonna get real
about divorce
don't let the door hit you with a good
lord split you after she officially left
him to go live with her friend julia
this episode
but while we wait for that let's go
ahead and get into chuck's disaster of a
cookout
today is the day of the family cookout
wow andre just had the most intense eye
roll
rebecca in general entitled [ __ ] and
charlie is just a broken ass prick
as we know andre has been fighting with
elizabeth's siblings
all season long after his father-in-law
chuck allowed him to join the family
business he's actually taking money out
of our pocket for our family the drama
so far has already caused
two physical altercations as a matter of
fact let's just call it three
do you not see what's going on because
libby and becky had this little sister
fight twice on the boat
do that to me and then we have the
moment when jen threw cake in andre's
face at his daughter's birthday party
leave my birthday house and yet chuck
thought bringing his kids back in one
space together
with no mediator therapist or even a
plan
what's a good idea what's going on dude
how's it going did you set this up
you and your family meetings thanks for
coming man
something about seeing chuck and andre
all buddy buddy with each other
it's uncomfortable you guys have
champagne are you celebrating another
deal or something
once libby's sisters becky and jen
arrived the tension
began to mount when was the last time
you called me
for my you know professional opinion on
an investment property do you remember
the last time you called me
it's been a while correct so you can see
why she thinks she's getting pushed out
no you're jealous that's what you are no
i'm not
that's enough what did you expect dad
remember how we used to get together and
there was no arguing
let's go back to those days for one day
please check
now i know you know a pretty please
please it's not gonna work with this
group
look who's back call the cops then
enters charlie
talking about call of the cops i have no
clue what he meant by that
but apparently he hasn't seen his dad or
siblings since the previous family
gathering chuck planned in maryland
you're not going to come into my
family's house and talk to me
to my family which also turned out to be
a mess like i said
don't tell me what to do
come on what's up hey what's up what's
up my son's coming into my house
this greeting
what are you doing stop it oh andre kind
of had charlie there
luckily production brought security i'm
assuming that's who
that is i bet [ __ ] honestly it felt
like this fight went on forever
the testosterone was on 10. these dudes
just wouldn't
let it go shut the [ __ ] then all of a
sudden you hear libby cursing someone
out
and it's charlie's wife of course it's
charlie's wifey
disgusting nails in my face according to
lib charlie's wife hit andre in the head
and that set her off trash
trailer trash
you want me to have a heart attack right
now i'm about to have a heart attack
obviously no one took chuck seriously
maybe he's used that tactic before
i don't know but if somebody i cared
about uttered those words out of their
mouth
i'm about to have a heart attack i'm
dropping
everything i'm shutting up what's
[Music]
and we're done you fight you better
settle down right now you fight with him
more down i will
okay well one thing that did quiet andre
for
second was the money of course it was
the money
if that means to put the business on the
line he's not worth even a single
touchdown from my side
i thought i was gonna see my family to
be
healed tonight but it got worse i cannot
believe
[Music]
i don't care about the business only
cares about my family
oh chuck i know this is not the right
time to say
you should have known this was gonna
happen so i'm not gonna say that
but what i will say is obviously it's
hard being a dad
especially to these kids if i'm not
being a good dad
you let this bitch-ass son love yours
you are
he's been trying to help libby and his
granddaughter out by giving andre these
opportunities
that's the only reason andre is working
for him right now
also similar to chuck i'm a big family
person
so i understand those tears anytime
there is drama between your loved ones
that you feel like you can't fix
is one of the worst feelings do you
think i'm cool with what's going on
right now
what as you can see the fight made its
way into the house
but then becky's husband came and shut
it down
i told you i'm not gonna like if he gets
in my proximity i'm gonna [ __ ] him up
that guy's toxic once i got outside
everybody started talking about how
charlie started the fight
and how he's toxic and you need to get
him help
you need to get nuts we've had some
drama because we have a big family
i have never never seen it this bad
before
my whole life he's got a vocabulary
five-year-old lunatic
to sit down and talk it through he's
incapable of that he came at home
this really turned into a worst-case
scenario situation
my family won't ever be the same after
tonight after the fight according to
becky she's leaving the family business
you honestly think i'm going to stay no
we don't need
charlie and his wife feel betrayed by
chuck whose side are you on
this is his dad's house not andre's
dad's house
i need to know what's up and andre has
given his father-in-law an ultimatum
he chose his ass now who like over the
rest of her family
or he chooses now like over us i'm over
this i'm over this chat
this was a really uh
traumatic night seeing my family so
so polarized
i don't write down what the best thing
is all i know is that i want my family
to heal
i want my family to come back
that's what i want i don't want to see
this i don't want to see my family
oh chuck hey sometimes the best thing
you can do when you don't know what to
do
is to allow time to work things out
all right well speaking of time kalani
and asuelu are going to need to find a
place of their own
soon because her mom revealed that she
and her husband lo
have decided to sell the house so they
can move closer to where he works in
california
i know that you guys had talked about
maybe getting your own place
well i think we wanted to wait a little
bit because of his accident and
everything to recoup that money
oh it's just real hard
lots of things that going through in my
mind i don't
know if i can handle the same time this
news
fellow and i swallowed like a ton of
bricks she doesn't want a baby
she doesn't want a baby because he still
was upset about the big fight they had
the previous
night with his mom and sister you're
ready to
smash them let's do it man
so to get some frustration out i'm ready
to break some
he decided to go to smash labs with his
samoan friend chewie
who seems like a super kind guy but
he ended up giving asuelu some advice
that in my opinion
wasn't the best for his particular
situation not sure
if i have a relationship with my mom
anymore she want money
for our father loving in summer but i
told her
i can't dance he told me that i lost my
culture
i've been more american but not to be
insensitive about your situation but
understand that's
what all of us are moons go through when
we come to america
so whatever i can't afford or whatever i
can to help the family
they're grateful uh yeah
he obviously hasn't met oswell's mom yet
if you need
money for food we can spend little
amounts of money when they were having
dinner he told her that he could give
her a little money here and there
and she said so while the whole they'll
be grateful for what they get attitude
might work for his friend situation
i'm not sure if it will work for asuelu
who
by the way ended up getting pretty
emotional where go find the
go steal from other people
go in the street and tell people give me
some money
i hope my family understand because
what they do it just makes me like
suffer
like i don't know what to do
so now you got to find a place to stay
because they're going to sell the house
yep this is just me everything i thought
about
taking your family back home to samoa
you've lived longer in america
than she has in samoa right yeah so
maybe it's a good chance for kalani to
go to samoa tui
actually convinced asuelu to ask her and
her reaction
was as expected maybe we can move to
samuel
build a house there it's your own land
you're not paying bills
you just plant your food near your house
you have your own land no
kalani explained why she said no saying
that she would be away from her family
and she would feel uncomfortable
but she did say they can visit i want to
go and have like a long visit we could
stay for like a month or two
that's when asuelu tried to guilt trip
her saying that he's changed for her and
the kids
and she hasn't done a thing oh yeah
he also told her that she wasn't a real
samoan woman
i want you to learn how to be a real
salmon girl
well then you should learn how to be a
real american man asuelu
just saying i think australia likes to
forget that i'm also half somewhat so
i still know the culture and i still am
rooted in a lot of parts of the culture
if you are real someone woman you want
more kids
and you respect my mom i'm a real samoa
woman regardless of all those things
my relationship with your mom does not
determine my dna
thank you very much speaking of asuelu's
mom
he revealed that he wants to give her
another chance
which kalani is against why have a
relationship with people who
don't give it about you that's a good
point
well we're going to see his mom and
tammy at the tell-all next week
and it looks like tammy is going to
start some more trouble
you better apologize to mom you were the
first one to jump
up my mom no that's why i got up i say
no you're not going to talk
too much seriously don't make me come to
you honey
please now she's threatening yara
i loved her response by the way honey
please
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because as usual we are covering it all
i will see you next time
foreign